meant to get this out a little bit  earlier in the day hope folks have had a  lovely valentine's day or that it  continues to be one depending on how  late in the day it is for you here's the  thing though  even though i haven't been single  on valentine's day for most of my life  it's kind of a [ __ ] holiday  i know it you know it single people  definitely know it so  here's the thing  my partner liz and i still wanted to do  something with the day we're still gonna  chase presents we're gonna have a nice  dinner and  we're just deciding that  instead of it being valentine's day  we're celebrating frederick douglass's  birthday  if you don't know who that is look him  up he's awesome and before someone jumps  on the wikipedia and goes oh we don't  know when he was actually born the man  picked february 14th as his chosen  birthday because yes he was born into  slavery and didn't know when he was born  but he was awesome this is his birthday  happy frederick douglass